[Musik]
hallo ihr Lieben heute gibt es mal
Getränke und zwar Summer Drinks schöne
eiskalte Getränke die euch die warmen
Temperaturen so ein bisschen
erträglicher machen wir starten jetzt
direkt ich schreibe euch wie immer alle
ganz genauen Mengenangaben und Mini
Infobox genau dort findet ihr immer
alles ganz genau ich lege jetzt direkt
los das erste das erste Getränk ist
jetzt mit Kaffee die anderen beiden sind
ohne Koffein ich starte jetzt oder mal
mit meinem
Macchiato dafür brauchen wir Kaffee
Eiswürfel einfach Kaffee grün und dann
hier in die eiswürfelförmchen gießen und
dann das ganze einfrieren das könnt ihr
euch super auf Vorrat vorbereiten
[Musik]
ich habe das hier mal vorbereitet
tada eingefrorene Kaffee Eiswürfel so
und das gebe ich jetzt direkt in mein
Glas ich bin natürlich nicht macht zwei
Gläser voll lieb von Dir gar nicht
gierig auch
die kommen jetzt einfach hier rein und
das coole ist da könnt ihr selbst
entscheiden wie viel Kaffee jetzt möchte
wie stark das ganze haben möchtet und
das Schöne ist ich bin ja so eine
Genießerin das heißt ich trinke ja meine
Getränke immer sehr langsam und
genussvoll und die Eiswürfel schmelzen
dann eben mit der Zeit also ganz langsam
und dann merkt ihr mit jedem Schluck so
ein bisschen mehr Kaffee Geschmack also
richtig cool die zweite wichtige
Komponente ist cremiges Eis und dann
nehmt ihr am besten das von Mövenpick in
der Sorte sorted Caramel da habt ihr
nämlich schon alle spannenden
Komponenten drin einmal die gesalzene
Karamellsoße und die toffifestückchen
und da gibt es jetzt eine ganz große
Kugel einmal in das Glas und füllt das
einfach nur noch mit Milch auf
[Musik]
ja dann mein testtest
mit einer Hand die Kamera hältst und mit
anderen funktioniert okay
meine Geschmack im Abgang richtig lecker
und
richtig cremig was macht die ganze Milch
total cremig das heißt
echt oder weiter geht's mit Rezept
Nummer zwei und das wird ein Zitroneneis
creak dafür nehmt ihr das Mövenpick
Zitronensorbet das ist aus
sizilianischen Zitronen und schmeckt
unfassbar gut und das coole ist dieses
Rezept ist ganz schnell gemacht das
heißt wenn ihr gar nicht viel Zeit in
der Küche ja verschwenden möchtet dann
macht es super super gerne und ich finde
es auch immer super wenn man zum
Beispiel grillt und dann zum Nachtisch
einfach noch so ein schönes kaltes
zitronengetränk anbietet da geben wir
jetzt tatsächlich nur noch Mineralwasser
dazu habe ich denn hier und das
Zitronensorbet erledigt den ganzen Rest
das Schmelzen nämlich auch innerhalb
wenigen Minuten und ich gebe da gerne
noch frische Zitronen oben drüber
einfach für die Optik ich finde das
macht noch mal ein bisschen was richtig
schick oder
eine edelbach
edel-bar ich finde es richtig schön
richtig schick und das ist so ein
bisschen schäumt und ich tue da jetzt
noch kurze Strohhalme mit dazu und dann
ist es auch schon fertig Zitrone könnte
man auch wenn man es noch süßer möchte
aber ich persönlich finde es so perfekt
[Musik]
auf uns und auf Euch auf so das coole
ist man sieht sogar die
zitronenfruchtstücke die im Eis mit drin
sind wenn man ganz genau hinschaut
das schmeckt gut sage ich doch richtig
richtig lecker richtig erfrischt keine
gesüßte Zitronenlimo dazu tun einfach
nur Mineralwasser es ist so lecker
einfach so am Strand liegen und dann das
bekommen
es ist wirklich unnormal lecker wirklich
unnormal unfassbar gut also macht's
unbedingt nach das ganze ist natürlich
auch vegan das zitronensorbevermögen ist
vegan ich habe jetzt auch extra geschaut
dass ich eine vegane Rezeptur finde und
es nicht mit Milch noch nehmen weil das
dritte Rezept ist auch wieder mit Milch
ein Shake ich bin gerade ein bisschen so
wie ich wusste gar nicht vegan ist cool
ist für alle was dabei hier heute so
let's go auch zum dritten Rezept für
unseren haselnuss-shake brauchen wir nur
zwei Zutaten einmal Milch da könnt ihr
die Milch nehmen die am liebsten
verwendet ich nehme ganz normale Milch
heute und da kommt jetzt Eis rein von
Mövenpick in der Sorte haselnuss- ch das
schöne ist wenn mir nicht nur
karamellisierte Haselnussstückchen
sondern auch eine haselnuss-soße und die
wird ganz fein in das gesamte Eis
eingesprudelt seht ihr das und da habe
ich eben auch wieder spannende
Komponenten mit dabei und brauchen gar
nicht mehr Zutaten außer eben das Eis
und die Milch und das ganze wird dann
wirklich nur ganz kurz vermisst ihr
könntet so ganz Schneebesen verwenden
noch ein bisschen Sahne und
Haselnusskerne und dann sind wir auch
schon fertig
[Musik]
ich bin ein bisschen traurig dass unsere
Reise jetzt endlich
lecker geworden also wir probieren mal
unseren Shake man kann wahlweise noch
eine Espresso hier rein machen
wenn du gutes Eis hast und aufregendes
Eis hast so wie hier bei uns dann
brauchst du nur noch Milch und ruckzuck
ist es fertig zubereitet wie gesagt
wahlweise gerne noch ein shot Espresso
reingeben aber es geht natürlich auch
komplett ohne und ich finde das rundum
perfekt sehr sehr lecker
das exe ich jetzt auch noch weg übrigens
den Shake könntet ihr auch mit Mövenpick
Hafer Cookie machen guckt euch mal die
Stückchen an da sind nämlich Haferkekse
mit drin und eine Karamellsoße schmeckt
auch sehr lecker und dann würde ich
sagen ich entlasse euch hinter euch wie
eine Schule so ein bisschen aber ich
hoffe dass ihr so ein bisschen
Inspiration sammeln konnte und schreibt
mir gerne in die Kommentare was euer
Favorit ist und wenn Ihr Rezept Nummer
zwei den Zitronen ein Drink mal probiert
habe dann schreibt unbedingt wie ein
fandet denn das ist wieder mal was ganz
anderes und die anderen zwei Rezepte
finde ich auch mega meine Top 3 Favorit
heute hier also ich wünsche euch viel
Spaß und sage bis zum nächsten Mal
tschüss ciao
ach übrigens auch ein ganz besonderes
Video weil haben so und ich wieder
Filmen das hatten wir jetzt auch lange
nicht mehr schreibt mal gerne in die
Kommentare ob wir das öfter so machen
soll dann haben sie sich mal ein
bisschen mehr Zeit nehmen auf jeden Fall
also bis dann tschüss